hello everyone anatoly karpov won a lot
of tournaments during his long chess
career but well this tournament he
really destroyed the field this is the
1994 linearis tournament and it featured
14 players of extreme caliber players
such as a world champion garry kasparov
Viswanathan Anand was there
Vladimir Kramnik Vasily von Schuch
Veselin Topalov gata Kamsky malevsky
also played there so definitely all of
the strongest players in the world were
playing this tournament and Karpov won
this tournament with 11 points out of 13
games and that's 9 wins 0 losses and 4
draws he won it with two and a half
points ahead of world champion Garry
Kasparov so definitely definitely
crushing the field and well not only
that also in this tournament he created
his immortal game against a Veselin
Topalov this was played in round 3
Karpov already won the first two games
he played and he has the white pieces
against young Veselin Topalov so Karpov
goes d4 we have Knight to f6 c4 c5 and
Knight to f3 avoiding the d5 and the
benoni defense C captures on d4 Knight
captures on d4 and ecigs g3 Knight to c6
Bishop to g2 Bishop to c5 and the
Knights to b3 kicking that bishop away
from c5 now black has a couple of
options here you can go Bishop b6 Bishop
b4 check but the poll was for Bishop to
e7 probably the safest choice nice to
see three top all of castles Karpov
castles and d6 Bishop to f4 and with
this Bishop f4 move well Karpov is
adding some nice pressure here on this
d6 pawn and you don't you don't really
want to play a move like 'if i this does
seem to be kicking the bishop away from
from where from f4
but after I move like Bishop to d2 you
will well permanently have a weakness
here on d5 and this d6 pawn will be weak
for the rest of the game
so instead after Bishop
four top Oliver went 492 h5 he wants to
get rid of the bishop well some other
way but Karpov doesn't retreat he plays
III opening up a discovered attack on
this night and age five and the top
olive isn't the kind of player that will
put the knight back to f6 so he captures
Knight captures on f4 and eliminates a
carp of the bishops pair on carpal plays
he captures on f4 and Bishop to d7 and
we have Queen to d2 now connecting rooks
and getting ready to develop develop
them and what so what's the plan here
for the power of the polymer plays a
queen to beat the Queen to b8 probably
with the idea of playing g6 Bishop to f6
and then maybe Finch arrowing the wish
or maybe g6 developing the rook Bishop
f8 and then putting the Bishop to g7
this seems like a plan for black but
it's not that easy to achieve this so
Karpov plays rook to e1 and we have g6
and you can see that the black has a
fianchetto formation here around his
King but he doesn't have a future of
Bishop so this is this is a pretty weak
setup so Karpov goes for h4 we have a
six and you can't really you can't
really play something like a bishop to
have six here to completely finish your
plan because Knight to e4 attacks your
Bishop on f6 and also this pawn on d6 so
you just have to go back with Bishop to
e7
so after h4 to Pablo's for a six and now
h5 we have B 5 by 2 pollo and H captures
on g 6h capture son g6 and here Karpov
plays Knight the c5 this isn't a peace
sacrifice as well if pawn captures night
then Queen captures this Bishop on d7
and well since the pallav doesn't really
have a use for this Bishop here it's not
really doing anything he allows it as he
doesn't see any threats that Karpov
might had have so he captures D captures
on c5 and Queen captures unbe 7 now
attacking this night with the Queen and
also with the bishop so we have a rook
to c8 now defending the
ending the night and well what do you do
here as white well why not capture the
night here with Bishop captures on c6
while if play Bishop captures on c6 this
seems like it's winning a piece but it's
really not
for example rook to a7 attacking the
Queen and after the Queen moves
well for example Queen to d3 you simply
capture the piece back rook captures on
c6 and this is somewhat of a drawn
position maybe it may be a bit better
for white but Karpov doesn't go for this
Karpov had a different completely
different idea after the Paula went rook
the c8 Karpov played rook captures on e6
it seems like he's sacrificing a rook
but it's really a brilliant idea what
happens if if you capture the rook well
if you capture the rook with F captures
on e6 you get Queen captures on e6 but
to check King to g7 and now Bishop
captures on c6 attacking the rook on a8
and well what do you play here for
example Queen to d6 Queen captures
Bishop captures and rook captures an a8
and after the bishop is captured simply
C captures on b5 a capture some b5 and
Knight captures mv5 carpel would be up
to pawns sorry three pawns with a
completely winning endgame
so after this rook to e6 idea by Karpov
the polliver
T'Pol decided to play rook to a seven as
now to Paulo now Karpov can't capture
the knight on c6 nor can he capture this
Bishop on e7 as his queen is attacked
but Karpov is determined to sacrifice
his rook and he plays rook captures on
g6 and well you can't really refuse this
offering as well for example if you go
King h8 you get made it with Queen to h3
and if you play something like King to
h7 again Queen to h3 check King captures
rook Bishop to e4 check and after a move
like f5 Queen captures and king to g7
Queen g6 check King has to go to f8 and
now Bishop to d5 threatening checkmate
on f7 and also on g8 you have to defend
this Bishop to d6 making room for the
king and e7 and after rook e1 cutting
off the King from the e-file well
there's really no way to prevent Queen
g8 checkmate you do you can prevent it
but you you will suffer a severe
material loss so okay after rook
captures on g6 the pol of decided to
capture the rook F capture sin g6 and we
have Bishop sorry Queen to e6 check
first King to g7 and now Bishop captures
on c6 and okay
I mean the pollo is the pollo is still
up the exchange but his King is a pretty
bare naked their rook to d8 bye-bye
Topalov and we have C captures on b5 and
this is this is I really enjoyed this
move if you're an aggressive player you
know you just sacrificed some material
and you want to go for the attack you
want to finish your opponent most
players will probably go for Knight to
e4 here adding more more pieces into the
attack but Karpov is a positional player
and he doesn't miss an opportunity to
capture a pawn so he goes see captures
on b5 and the power plays at Bishop to
f6 he wants to consolidate his position
and only now Knight to e4 now with a
tempo on the bishop bishop to d4 and
well here again if you were an
aggressive player you might get ideas
like f5 you know to completely go for
the attack or maybe even King to g2 to
bring the rook into the attack with rook
to h1 but again Karpov doesn't miss an
opportunity to grab a pawn and he plays
B captures on a6 well you don't really
want to recapture this pawn as this rook
is well doing a great job defending the
seventh rank so Karpov just grabs the
pawn I mean what a gentleman
Queen to b6 by Topalov and we have
worked to d1 and well it seems like you
do have some tactics here but you don't
really for example Bishop captures an f2
although we do attack this row can be
won now after Knight captures that the
rook is defended so this is out of the
question
so after rook to d1 the power grab
this pawn on e6 this dangerous past pawn
to Queen captures on a6 and what do you
do here if you're Karpov
well this Bishop is guarding f6 and well
you really do want to get your Queen to
f6 so what do you do you remove the
defender rook captures and d4
sacrificing the second exchange we have
rook after son before and now Queen to
f6 check and now Karpov has a firm grip
on top allows King King to g8 we have
Queen captures and g6
King f8 and now okay
Queen to h6 wins the game a lot more
quickly than then the move Karpov played
but this was over the board you know the
clock is ticking so it's important to
find any winning move not the one that
wins the fastest so Karpov played the
Queen to eight with check in with the g7
and now Queen to e5 check King to g8
Knight to f6 with check King to f7
Bishop - I ate with check and well you
don't really want to go to g7 to allow
some nasty discoveries Karpov goes King
to f8 and now Queen captures on c5 would
check attacking this rook here on on d4
so Quinta d6 defending and now a simple
move Queen captures rook on a7
threatening Queen to f7 checkmate
so Queen captures on f6 is played and
here carpet plays Bishop to h5 and this
is preventing any rook to d1 check ideas
also when the King comes to g2 this
Bishop to f3 will be a really great
defensive plan and what did Karpov get
from all of this
the pollo is still up the exchange but
Karpov is up five pawns this is well
five points for a row for the exchange
this is just too much rock to d2
attacking that pawn and b2 and also well
maybe adding pressure to that f2 pawn
but this is all very unlikely
b3 defending rook to b2 and after King
to g2 to Paulo resigned the game as
there is well there is nothing he can do
in this
white is what is just up too much
material whatever black plays for
example even let's say he checks the
King after a move like Bishop to f3
there really is no more attacking ideas
here for black and white will just push
for example this a pawn to victory so
after this think the g2 move the power
resigned the game and Karpov is three
out of three and will continue to win
games all all the way to round eight I
believe he was seven out of seven before
he drew his first game against Alexey
sure of so yeah definitely one of one of
Karpov greatest tournament victories and
you know if you'd like I will put a link
to this linearis tournament in the
description below so you can check out
some of some of the other games I will
probably do more games from this
tournament not all of them of course but
you know I do recommend you check them
out so yeah that's the game that Karp of
immortal of linearis 1994 I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon